now now September for me Ryan has been a
hard month and thankfully I have a
simple relationship with Becks
it's not simplistic absolutely it is not
that what you were gonna say yeah that's
not a simplistic relation right it is
intentional and it is curated but I've
had a really hard time and X has been
really supportive so I've tried that so
I won't get into too deep on the the you
know if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while I've had a bunch of
health problems last two-and-a-half
years and finally really dialed them in
July and August two best months of my
life because I cut down the only eating
five foods I was eating meat and greens
and coffee and chocolate and what was
the other thing water I think all fat
like oils that was it
and in September I I started like
reintroducing some some carbs back in
because I knew that long term I didn't
want to be on you know a full carnivore
diet or whatever written really useful
and radically reducing inflammation but
I wanted to bring more plants back into
my life and in doing so it made me
really sick and I've actually heard this
from people I got really depressed last
week man and I'm dude I don't use that
word I don't in fact I don't think I've
ever used that word to describe my
emotions I'm sorry dude when you call me
well yeah I was I mean I thought the
backs about it well you got someone to
talk to
yeah in depression is like depression is
no joke dude well I don't depression is
worse than sadness to me Oh way worse
yeah in fact is worse than despair like
I felt despair in the past and the
reason I don't use depression I don't
take it lightly as both of my parents
were clinically depressed well my mother
was a depressive my father was a
manic-depressive schizophrenic and so
there's certainly a lot of like family
history with that and I've never been a
person who experiences depression over
the last couple years I've experienced
despair because I'm like man I'm never
gonna heal I've got all these
inflammation problems the back problems
my gut problems the c-diff all of these
problems that I had and I felt despair
like oh there's no hope for the future
kind of thing but I never got into this
this crippling depression and there was
a day last week where I'm just
I do not want to be alive anymore MA III
just damn dude it was I've never felt
those depths before is it is it a
symptom of everything of the health
problems leading up or was it just a
feeling of like were you depressed
because of the health problems or did
the health problems lead to you all of a
sudden just being depressed does that
question make sense it does I think it
was it has more - it's horrible so
bringing these certain foods back in and
with my certain gut issues that I have
it changed the you know the chemical
makeup of my body and and in doing so it
made things that before would have been
annoying or saddening or frustrating it
them to the point where I felt like
stuck and felt like everything was
pointless and it was a really dark place
to be I feel like things are pointless
all the time it's not a depressive
feeling though it's actually kind of a
freeing feeling well about how we give
so many things these meanings but it's
like I'm gonna be dead in 50 years dude
but yeah and that's the problem is I'm
like well I'm gonna be dead in 50 years
why not just be dead now yeah it's it's
yeah and I've never I've never felt what
I felt last week and it was a
combination of certain things and
feeling stuck and and I had to do with
the and the chemical makeup of you know
and so I talked to my doctor and he's
like yeah well go back to what you were
eating and then very slowly reintroduce
things because I was trying to introduce
a bunch of things at once basically like
I'm ready to start taking back on some
of these these carbohydrates no junk no
processed foods I died is pristine but
like let's incorporate some of these
things back in and as I did that like it
put me into this downward spiral and it
was really rough and I'm I'm definitely
not all the way out of it but there was
a there was a a period of a week where
it was like I'm feeling like like I
there was one day I looked at backs I
said I literally feel like I woke up on
the wrong side of the bed dammit dude I
feel like yeah I feel like just a lot of
times you were like oh my god
I've never felt healthier now why your
legis I'm so depressed
what and is like in it maybe even more
depressing I'm like AHA man maybe I just
should why I'm so stupid I can't believe
I brought these foods back in I was
feeling so great and now I'm doing this
like I did this i self-sabotage and like
and what I realized I was back in
Missoula when this happened I what I
realized is there was there's a whole
lot of trauma that I associated with
with Missoula like really absolutely Wow
because the peak of my health problems
where I thought I was dying member
October 2016 I thought I was dying and
then every time I go back to Missoula
now I feel there's a trauma attached to
that so I'm reaching out to my therapist
and we're gonna have some conversations
about it I've worked with a therapist
through nourish balance thrive and we're
gonna have some conversations about it
and trying to better understand like how
in fact I what I'd love to do because
neither one of us we both of us have a
lot of trauma in our childhood and and
the funny thing is like there's some
things that should be traumatic
they aren't traumatic to me because I
don't associate trauma with it right
yeah but there are other things that
like we can associate like I can't
believe the lights came on in the during
the middle of the podcast and there's
some sort of trauma there yeah and for
me like that's the other thing that made
me depressed being back in Missoula
where I was like this everything is
going great in our lives right now we
just signed the big deal I can't talk
about yet belay our next big project
that I'm looking forward to sharing with
the world like that was great the Today
Show and Megan Kelly are coming out to
our houses this weekend to like film us
and and I'm back in the Zula this
beautiful place and like all these
things I'm like if I were to like
objectively look at the pro and con list
my column of pros is just like boom boom
boom everything is great but I feel this
way I feel a component in that that
actually made it feel me made me feel
more despair like everything's going
really well
and I feel bad yeah and it's not that I
even wanted all of these things to
happen or anything it's not like I was
striving for them which is good things
are happening there's always a beautiful
place but I have a certain amount of
trauma associated with that place and I
need to work that out yeah dude the
other thing too man and
you know not they're opposed dude you
were the type of person that well do one
when at the end of 2014 when your health
issues really started to kick in during
tour mm-hmm um at the end of tour I'm
like dude like you need to take a month
off and you're like yeah I need to take
him one thoth mhm and then like you took
the month of December off and I remember
you call him and you're like yeah I was
pretty much gonna kill myself not doing
anything yeah so you are this type of
person who you will fill your plate up
as much as you can mm-hmm and you know
if it's too little you don't feel good
mm-hm and if it's too much you don't
feel good right so it is this constant
balance of trying to because you just
listed off all these pros that's all we
got a lot of pros going on yeah we got a
lot of pros going on huh so maybe that's
something to think about too is what is
there anything we need to take off our
plates man right you know I mean that
might be I don't know no you're
absolutely right and being willing to
let go of any of those things so that
you can and we are arrived yeah I mean
anything that that's the thing we say no
to so many other like wonderful
opportunities right now like thankfully
we have the vice president of know over
here mr. podcast Shawn he's allowed to
say no to everyone for us it makes
things easier for us hey you have a
project you want to work with the song
just send us an email so podcast Shawn
can tell you no and it's not that we
don't want to do it she's gonna have the
bandwidth I mean yesterday I mean do we
I get at least one email a day or a
tweet
hey I got something I want to work with
you I want to partner up with you on its
write wish I could say yes the old 400
requests I get a year even even even
with our own team yesterday I mean
Jessica whom I love and she has a bunch
of great ideas I had to say no to her on
about 4 different things she wanted to
work on yesterday because I'm like I
just I and it's just me being honest
look I don't have the bandwidth to do
that yeah I would love to do that I just
know that in order to say yes that I'm
gonna say no to something else that I've
already said yes to
you